endlich zum eigentlichen Problem dieses
Spätsommers woke Wichtigtuer wollen
Winnetou weg haben ja ein Schock
übrigens auch für Winnetou persönlich
der ist aus der Bild-Zeitung erfahren
musste er wusste es gar nicht
phasenweise wurde der Suchbegriff
Winnetou in Deutschland häufiger
gegoogelt als Inflation oder Strompreis
was war geschehen sie wissen es
wahrscheinlich der Ravensburger Verlag
hat das Buch zum Film der Junge
Häuptling Winnetou zurückgezogen und das
war ja nur der Anfang inzwischen will
man Winnetou ein Mann der mehr für den
Frieden im Wilden Westen getan hat als
jeder andere komplett vermieten komplett
also sagt die Bild und das weiß die Bild
aus der Bild wenn du zu geht seinen
Kragen schon mal auf die Seite eins der
Zeitung heute zack in die Jagdgründe
geschickt in die ewigen der Winnetou ja
aus lauter hat politischer Korrektheit
aus woknis ne ganz genau ja
Bild TV zitiert also die Bild-Zeitung
diese alte journalistenregel du brauchst
immer zwei Quellen dann stimmt
seitdem hört die Diskussion an deutschen
Lagerfeuern gar nicht mehr auf sie will
sich einfach nicht beruhigen weil
eigentlich das noch mal Buch zum Film
zurückgezogen wurde es wirklich die
unterste Form von Literatur noch unter
glücksradgebern na gut ich ich privat
finde Ravensburger hätte das Buch lieber
ausliefern sollen dann könnten Eltern
selber entscheiden ob das für ihre
doofen Kinder zu stereotyp ist vor allem
aber wer uns die nervige
Berichterstattung zu Winnetou Gate
erspart geblieben inklusive der ganzen
Promi Meinung oder aufhören Walt Disney
sprechende enden wie tut man dieser
Tiergarten dieser Abend Tiergattung
ja so klingt also Honig im Kopf ja
schätze den Mann sehr ja es ist ja so
der Deutsche sehnt sich halt in diesen
Tagen nach einfachen Problemen Klima
Ukraine das ist alles viel zu komplex
aber Winnetou verbieten das kapiert
jeder selbst wenn es gar nicht stimmt
ich meine es gab ja auch nie den
behaupteten Shitstorm vor dem
Ravensburger angeblich eingeknickt ist
da haben sich in der Realität wirklich
eine Hand vor Leute im Internet
beschwert shit gestorben wurde nämlich
erst als die bildschicht draufgesetzt
hat und seitdem wimmelt es auch in der
Politik nur so von selbst ernannten
deutschen Ehren Apachen
die Kinder heute wieder Cowboy und
Indianer spielen würden anstatt irgendwo
verrückte comic-sendungen mit schrägen
Figuren anschauen würden wo man auf
Nacht nicht mehr schlafverko wo die
Kinder Angst kriegen dass die
Fingernägel Weg fressen
und begrabt mein Hirn an der Biegung des
Flusses
wenn ich sowas höre da möchte ich mir
auch die Fußnägel wegfressen Freunde der
Kampf für Winnetou wirklich wochenlang
auf allen Kanälen irgendwann wurde sogar
behauptet das war der Höhepunkt die ARD
hätte Winnetou gecancelt da waren die
Kollegen einfach vor zwei Jahren die
Rechte für die alten Filme nicht mehr
verlängert um zu sparen welcher Dödel
fällt bitte auf solche bullshit-meldung
rein wer
die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen hochgeloben
finanziell gut ausgestattet geben das
Geld auch sicher sehr sinnvoll aus meine
Damen und Herren wie man liest
sagen wir verlängern keine Verträge mehr
damit weil wir andere nicht verletzen
wollen ja Herrgott sagt meine Damen und
Herren
herrgottsack sagt man nicht mehr es
heißt Frau Gott segin
mein Gott da spart die ARD endlich mal
und dann meckerte auch und sie ahnen
bestimmt wer sich aus Söder Stamm auch
direkt zu Wort gemeldet hat genau
Häuptling verkackte Maut natürlich
ja
zitatscheuer ich gehe jetzt erstmal
winnetou-material Hamstern bevor die ARD
noch alles aufkauft ja mach das mal in
der Zeit unterschreibst du wenigstens
keine neuen Verträge
original niemand will Karl meis Bücher
verbieten oder diese 60er Jahre Filme
die ich damals ja selber gern geguckt
habe begeistert mit sieben spricht ja
auch nichts dagegen wobei muss ich
zugeben wenn ich heute genau hingucke
wird da eigentlich nur stundenlang
sinnlos hin und her geritten die
Indianer waren Jugoslawen mit schlecht
sitzenden Perücken und es wurde ohne
Ende gelogen Winnetou begrüßt rote Feder
rote feders Fehler ist weiß Lex Barke
hatte insgesamt zwei Gesichtsausdrücke
also genau ein mehr als Til Schweiger
die Stunts waren unterirdisch und die
fake-beeren sogar noch unterirdischer
Tiefpunkt Winnetou 3 diese endlose
sterbe Szene immer wenn du denkst jetzt
ist er aber tot zurück ist er wieder
kurz gesagt diese Filme waren nicht in
erster Linie Stereotyp die waren einfach
nur kacke
Shitstorm in drei zwei wir hatten ja
nichts liebe Kinder karl May war unser
Marvel-Universum ja aber warum sollte
das heute irgendwer verbieten wollen
seine vollkommen entgleiste Debatte
jetzt Rennen immer noch Reporter von
morgens bis abends in Buchhandlung und
überprüfen ob da noch die alten
Schwarten rumstehen während die
woke-seite des Spektrums über 100 Jahre
alte Fantasy-Romane mit Sachbüchern über
amerikanische Geschichte verwechselt
aber noch viel wichtiger was wird jetzt
aus dem Karl-May-Festspielen sie wissen
schon Bad Segeberg Elspe diese ganzen
Gnadenhöfe für abgehalfterte
b-schauspieler
haben die noch eine Zukunft
auf der Freilichtbühne in Bad
Salzdetfurth beginnen die Proben für die
ersten komplettpolitisch korrekten Karl
May Festspiele für die Schauspieler ein
großer Moment ja das wird super man kann
die Abenteuer von Winnetou Old
Shatterhand nämlich auch sehr wohl
zeitgemäß erzählen als modernes Epos
über interkulturelle Freundschaft doch
auch in dieser Inszenierung gibt es
natürlich die klassischen
Gänsehautmomente Winnetou und Old
Shatterhand reiten durch das weite Land
nur halt auf e-lastenrädern walpferde so
eine wahnsinnig schlechte methan-bilanz
haben
mein Bruder sie nur der weiße Mann hat
eine neue Eisenbahnlinie mitten durch
unsere Jagdgründe gebaut
Winnetous Herzes betrübt weil das
eiserne Rost die Büffel vertreibt nein
weil das 9 Euro Ticket ausgelaufen ist
wir quatschen können sich nun keine
Urlaubsreisen mehr leisten
anders als in den alten Filmen lernen
hier die Kulturen endlich voneinander
Old Shatterhand erklärt den
wissbegierigen Ureinwohnern die größte
Errungenschaft seiner deutschen Heimat
die gelbe Tonne so also nochmal
Joghurtbecher ja
biberfell nein dafür bereiten die
Apachen ihn auf die Legalisierung von
weichen Drogen vor wann
du das Zeug ballert aber ganz schön
zum ersten Mal wird diese legendäre
Szene realistisch dargestellt Winnetou
und Old Shatterhand besiegeln ihre
Freundschaft mit Blut mein Bruder mein
Bruder und werden kurz danach wegen
affenpotten in die Klinik gebracht nur
drei Monate später gehen die Proben
weiter ja wir finden das natürlich total
toll dass wir hier endlich mal diese
ganzen Stereotypen überwinden diese
postkoloniale Weltsicht und gerade ich
als indigender Mensch finde das extrem
wichtig wieso in die gehen du kommst
doch aus Braunschweig du sagst mir nicht
wie in die gehen ich bin okay glaubst du
dass es einfach als Apache geboren zu
sein im Körper eines Niedersachsen weißt
du wie man da gehänselt wird in der
Schule als Junge Apache in Braunschweig
Albrecht wirklich für dich immer noch
weit später
mal runter
jedes Kind weint wenn der ruchloses
Center Winnetou tötet doch diese
Inszenierung geht einen anderen Weg den
gewaltlos stirb wohl Winnetou
Santander ja du wirst ja wohl nicht auf
Winnetou schießen der hatte doch gar
nichts getan
naja
stimmt
es tut uns so Leid zu Klärung ich und
die Jungs wir hatten eine total schwere
Kindheit und das hat uns leider zu
gewalttätigen Rassisten gemacht aber wir
haben gemerkt das war falsch
Schwamm drüber
[Musik]
der wird alles ein Yogi-Tee das alles
nächstes Jahr in der neuen Inszenierung
von der Ölprinz eröffnet einen Windpark
und heißt deshalb der erneuerbare
Energien Prinz
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfonds alles
dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten